i bet you think you know about
einstein's famous formula e equals mc
squared
but what i bet you didn't know is that
that famous formula was only very
recently confirmed
116 years after it first appeared and
today we're going to take a deep dive
into how this was experimentally
verified in just the past few months
come along
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
no formula in all of science is better
known and recognized than e equals mc
squared but few people know
that that formula was basically taken on
faith at least in the condition where
one can convert energy into mass e
energy is related to mass via the famous
speed of light squared but how can this
be verified first of all we know that in
certain nuclear reactions the conversion
of mass via nuclear fission or even
fusion can result in energy differences
that get liberated or produced in the
form of huge thermonuclear explosions
but for generations now scientists have
used the tools of quantum field theory
that encode within them the notion of
what are called virtual photons and the
interconversion between these virtual
photons and particles of matter say
electrons or protons and the production
of very real photons that can be
detected and in the 1930s two physicists
by the name of gregory bright and john
archibald wheeler came up with a
prediction that would go undetected and
unmeasured until this very year in 2021.
breit was a physicist of the 20th
century who made many predictions
related to nuclear and particle physics
and also contributions to the production
of technology used in radar which was
alongside the manhattan project one of
the foundational technologies that
allowed the allies to win in triumph in
world war ii
the second man almost needs no
introduction on this channel john
archibald wheeler who was many things
including an advisor to richard feynman
the corner of the term black hole and
many other contributions to physics and
wheeler created the wheeler-dewitt
equation so-called quantum cosmology the
wave function for quantum cosmological
origin that we've talked about on this
channel but in this context he worked
specifically after world war ii on
interactions between light and matter
and of course his star student richard
feynman went on to win the nobel prize
in 1965 for this discovery of the
interaction between light and matter
that we call quantum electrodynamics or
qet so the bright wheeler process is the
interconversion of photons particles of
light into matter into manifestations of
actual ordinary honest-to-goodness
matter and mass that could be then
predominantly it could be weighed it
could be interacted with and it could be
used to measure the strength of this
interaction between photonic matter and
ordinary matter one of the foundational
properties of modern physics are
conservation laws one such conservation
law is that you cannot create or destroy
energy therefore the energy the e in the
e equals m c squared equation has to go
into an equivalent amount of mass now
that mass can also not be of the form of
two like charges for the reason that
that would violate conservation
of charge so you couldn't create two
electrons or two positrons for example
they must come in pairs to cancel out
the two photons crashing together have
zero electrical charge together they
have zero net momentum so you must
create particles that are antimatter and
matter so namely an electron and a
positron the production of equal and
opposite amounts of matter and
antimatter along with the conservation
of momentum means that if you do produce
matter from pure energy from your pure
photons you could produce actual matter
antimatter pairs and this is exactly
what was measured by the rick
relativistic heavy ion collider in upton
new york which is on long island
brookhaven near where i was born almost
50 years ago
in this laboratory phenomenal
discoveries have taken place for
over 50 years but in this case there was
an experimental verification of proof
that the bright wheeler process takes
place they found at rick that physicists
could accelerate atoms to extremely high
speeds approaching the speed of light
and they could test a variety of
different properties and phenomena at
those energies this facility was almost
uniquely qualified to test the veracity
of the bright wheeler process so let's
go back to the basics really quickly
number one we know that light is
quantized into discrete
bunches of energy called photons
number two we know that light is made up
of electromagnetic waves
number three we know that static
electrons produce an electric field
and four from maxwell's equations we
know that a current or electrons in
motion produce a magnetic field
we also know that metallic elements such
as gold have many free electrons that
can participate in interactions such as
the type that the bright wheeler
phenomenon describes
so what happens if you take a heavy
metal not the rock kind but you take
heavy metal like gold and accelerate it
to very high speeds so it has its
electrons in high velocity configuration
they will produce electromagnetic waves
and how those electromagnetic waves
interact when another atom of a gold not
a nucleus an atom of gold passes by so
if you take an ion which is an atom
whose ha which has had some of its
electrons stripped away and you pass say
the nucleus of atoms uh very close to
one another at extremely high speeds as
shown here their
motion the electronic charges in motion
in the nucleus will interact with each
other once they get within a close
enough rain what physicists at the rick
accelerated brookhaven were able to do
is pass these two ions very close to one
another and the nuclei of gold has 79
protons that's an awful lot of
electronic charge in motion produces
some degree of electromagnetic field
that electromagnetic field can interact
and that interaction produced a
concomitant signal which was then
observed and used to infer the existence
of the interconversion between energy
photonic energy and some creation of
mass in the form of matter antimatter
pairs so when these were accelerated to
relativistic velocities their
electromagnetic fields their electric
and magnetic fields converge so this
veiled cloud of photons surrounding each
one of the gold ions as they pass
extremely close to one another those
photons interact with one another and
there's a possibility for a matter
antimatter production to occur from a
photon photon interaction of this cloud
this veil surrounding each nucleus or
each ion the researchers at rick were
able to confirm exactly this prediction
was what happened as these ions passed
close by on one another they discovered
that electrons and positrons were
ejected the implicit belief being that
this overlap of the virtual photon
fields were actually produced by the
bright wheeler process now how can you
actually confirm that it was part of
this so you have to rule out the fact
that this could be produced via other
mechanisms now what is actually
happening is whether or not these
photons are so-called real photons or
virtual photons a virtual photon is not
a photon that doesn't exist rather it's
a quantum fluctuation a transient one
that due to the famous heisenberg
uncertainty principle they're actually
well accepted in quantum field theory
especially in the work of as i mentioned
earlier richard feynman in perturbation
theory and quantum field theory and
quantum electrodynamics when you have
interactions between ordinary real
particles like electrons and positrons
you can think of them as exchanging
virtual particles and some of these
particles in the context of electron
positron scattering or pear production
can be thought of as virtual photons
these appear often in feynman diagrams
such as the one i'll show here and
they're usually represented by wiggly
lines and internal
internal interactions meaning that we
don't actually observe them they don't
actually carry the same mass a virtual
electron doesn't carry the same mass as
a corresponding real electron but they
do conserve energy and they solve many
of these problems that had vex
physicists in the early part of the 20th
century so the longer the particle will
live for sort of the longer one has to
violate this uncertainty principle of
the uncertainty and energy multiplied by
the uncertainty in time equal to or
proportional to the reduced planck's
constant i like to think of these
virtual particles sort of like crooked
accountants in physics in that they kind
of steal from their clients but then
they replace the money fast enough that
the client never notices it was gone you
know did a crime occur did they not i
don't condone any of this and none of
this is financial advice that's one way
to think about them you can borrow on a
short enough time scale such that it
can't be detected via any observation
and
and of course these are integral to
modern quantum field theory
so the researchers wanted to know and
they calculated the angles of emission
of the electron positron pairs now the
angles that come out are exactly related
to calculations done by bright and
wheeler almost a century ago and the
question is do they obey the principles
of real photons or virtual photons and
the experimenters go into great detail
as shown in the paper here the actual
reaction trajectories of the electron
and positron depend on whether or not
their pair production is caused by
virtual photons versus real photons so
the researchers spent a great deal of
time talking about this confirming that
this was actually an example of real
honest-to-goodness photons interacting
not virtual photons not these crooked
accountants but actual
honest-to-goodness photons converting
their energy into
matter via e equals m c squared so i bet
you now know what you already thought
you know which is that e equals m c
squared is not just a good idea it's the
law it holds both in the creation of
nuclear energy from both vision and
fusion processes and it actually can
occur from the entanglement the
interaction between honest-to-goodness
photons the energy pure energy no mass
converting to honest-to-goodness
particles of mass the positron and the
electron and the exact representation as
predicted almost 100 years ago by bright
and wheeler remains a crucial
verification yet again if you have any
doubt that einstein was correct does
that mean that einstein was never wrong
probably not he was certainly wrong on
many occasions as we've talked about in
other videos and we'll undoubtedly talk
about again i want to draw your
attention that there's also a concept
discovery by the same researchers at
rick that relates to what's known as
birefringence and we'll talk about that
in an upcoming episode but for now i
thank you for going into the impossible
with yours truly brian keating
chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics at uc san diego co-director of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination leave a comment and what you
thought about this video and whether or
not you think that virtual photons
should be arrested
you